tessier mémoire lenk be well brûlés
alors pas pouvoir aller on va faire
enfin j'ai offert un arbre on va
l'appeler moche moche et vilains voilà
c'est extrêmement bien alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut choisir comme crème fraude
prostitution pour l'institution il s'est
prostituée saturn qui a accepté de
coucher avec un mec avec une tête
écrasée comme ça et si la fin facepalm
et que ça a mal tourné genre oh non
alors on est au tribunal à légumes qui
l'a embauché vilain cette cour
tu accuses de prostitution et veut
entendre ta défense en fait j'étais là
comme ça en maths tonnes de lin billets
de 3,5 au ces primes peine de 34 jours
denses aux teintes correctional facility
c'est quoi ce public derrière alors on a
des gros seins on a un mec qui se prend
pour batman on a slamé spitzberg oh mon
dieu il est fait en allant regarder et
wat
pourquoi je garde ça pour que ce garage
et de savate right on va la prendre au
bahut gros tricks est très utile batrak
attend d eux à cul non w c'est parce que
vous croyez
le téléphone est tombé je les justes
revit c'est parce que vous croyez
il est où il est au d où vient la vient
tu fais moi le balançant sa matraque 1
puisque qu'est ce que tu fais avec ce
avec cette matraque tu l'a jeté par
terre mais que j'ai juste pris pour te
casser la gueule et m'échapper de prison
pourquoi qu'est le problème
1 quel est le problème je n'aime pas
trop le mec qui fait mais c'est pas de
la faute elle apparue dans ma main
banquet des boîtes à oeufs en mal qu'aux
ce blog c'est par là allez j'arrive
bande de merde et les poteaux comment ça
va est ce qu'on peut pas aller dans
qu'est ce qu'ils vont lui est moche et
vilains tu dois être un attardé
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un d'aussi stupide
que toi vas-y le gardien trappe le jeu
mais mon dieu non ça que je suis choisi
hugh mais c'est la guerre dans cette
prison quoi c'est une prison où c'est à
une sorte d' endroit où tout le monde se
fait connaître pour défoncer ya un
gardien pour vingt prisonniers qu'il
faut absolument naouet quoi bon moi je
propose qu'on robail sur 7 sur cette
plante
quoi quoi qu'est ce qui est à moi j'ai
regretté plantes moi mais j'ai trop peur
des gardiens et vos mots stoppée net
alors on va aller voir mon compagnon de
cellule a hélas mon compagnon de cellule
il est là salut qu'en karkwa peau c'est
quoi ce délire arrête je m'en vais
arrête regard des gardiens quoi regarder
le je suis dans ma cellule
oh mon dieu liénard toi je vais te
défoncer retenez bien sa tête lui on va
le défoncer la main ils se croient
malins l'aï regardé on voit cette
culotte a trait à son jeans en plus
grosse année en fait j'ai plus de vie
watts et est ce que cet homme
regardez-le une espèce de gros kéké de
la prison quoi boyard m'échappe d'euros
tu tape dedans tu casses de point et tu
arrives dans cette poule seront en fait
j'ai plus de vie puisque l'autre m'a
pété la gueule c'est vous que je trouve
de la vie ce devait être la bataille
allez va au hall principal et je vous
promets on revient on chope le couteau
flotte tout à ce que je fais ce que tu
as welcome to the man all - chez vilain
c'est le coeur de la prison anti à
utiliser le maquis par les cheveux à
temps oh non je suis mort la richesse va
tout seul gisement si je m'appuie sur la
touche taper texte un des dialogues dure
quatre heures les lettres watts mettais
ma le tien est moche et vilains qu'est
ce que c'est ton problème je pensais
qu'on était ami parlons pas trop je
chercherai juste l'infirmerie s'il vous
plaît tu es rien à part une chatte moche
et ville un mec sait déjà il s'est passé
un truc avec condettois donc les boîtes
watts alors toi mon gars tiens pourquoi
elle a fait ça non c'est pas le faire un
salto arrière mon gars tiens tiens non
mais pourquoi la pression je cherchais
juste une infirmerie
quant aux dames ap raisonner avec un
katana voulu m'agresser hospital oui
est-ce qu'on va se taper une espèce de
grosse infirmières bien canon en mode
voulez que je vous souhaite
mais ça se tape même dans l'hôpital je
veux juste être soigné s'il vous plaît
je ne veux pas participer à votre poste
pardon je suis juste un peu malade ok il
faut une dose de drogue apparemment pour
tu peux aussi donner de la monnaie est
bon on voulait que je lis des dialogues
comme on sait qu'à l'ipad tombée pendant
que tu besoin de quoi sont décodés là il
ya plein de médoc là sur la table non
sur la table nos sur la cab va sur la
chaise
ouais ok les mecs question qu'est ce
qu'un bon je vais me poser sur un lit
allez il peut pas quoi en fait ce qui me
fait chier c'est qu'il peut pas courir
ça fait vingt minutes que j'essaie juste
de me soigner bordel à les espaces de
voix leurs deux lits va te faire [ __ ]
au regard des cieux apporté rien suis à
par terre à l'épreuve en une comme enjeu
l'utilisent oui ma vieille route non à
oui c'est bon j'ai de la vie non parce
que je voulais faire mais j'ai
l'impression que des fois mon perso je
le contrôle plus tu es sous arrestation
pour avoir attaqué un gardien
c'était que les deux gardiens il en est
il à un tournevis dans la main depuis
tout à l'heure les deux guardian of
light
moi je peux excuser moi est-ce que je
peux juste mettre un coup de poing à
merci elles me font tuer sous what an
mais non mais attendez quatre jours de
plus et je vais devoir payer 100 dollars
de dommages aux les bâtards aller voilà
j'ai encore mc gastro la [ __ ] quand
vous les jeux gagnés qu'un avocat
cassette tête quoi on dirait qu'il a vu
une fille comme ça et qui faisait cette
tête
très bien alors au final on s'est pris
quelques jours de plus en plus on doit
payer 100 dollars et j'étais toujours
pas de vie mais non mais regardez
regardez regardez les deux gardiens se
bat et regarder si j'en ai dit je vais
je me faire défoncer je m'en vais je
nomme je mens et je m'en vais je m'en
vais laisse-moi laisse maintenant
laissez moi je participe à votre baston
à de frank rijkaard et longeant les
marchés comme ça tu vous défoncer
ouattara jusqu'à qu'est-ce qui attend
même agacé un mannequin dessus l'autre
résumé ce prêt du jeu
howie des lots team défaut très bien
on aurait dit une scène un peu érotique
est ce que j'ai fait au bercail c'est
tout qu'est ce qu'il ya tiens watts et
voilà je leur fais arrêter
bon été beaucoup d'argent supplémentaire
de la pression être une [ __ ] mais vous
avez vu là-bas attendait non sans
déconner je n'ai pas rêvé y avoir une
sorte de fantôme d'un amuse pas 14 en
train de psychoter la gc de vh vous
l'avez bien un [ __ ] de fantômes là ils
avançaient comme ça s'est fait très peur
la vespière but